about books saturday and sunday nights
at 9 eastern end pacific time
next a new version of the adventures of
huckleberry finn
the book just published by random house
contains a recently discovered partial
manuscript of mark twain's classic
you'll see a panel on the novel with
historian shelby foote mark twain
biographer justin kaplan novelist
william styron and essayist roy blount
prince staples of the new york times
moderates the panel and actor bill
murray reads from the book
good evening
okay is this on
hello good evening
i'm steve riggio chief operating officer
of barnes and noble and i'd like to
welcome everyone here to what will
surely be a very lively evening
you know it's always a pleasure to
introduce new writers as we often do
here at barnes noble just a month ago i
was
introducing chang ray lee the author of
native speaker and he won our discover
great new writers award for 1995.
tonight we're here to rediscover not
just a great author but a new edition of
one of his most important works
i was going to introduce our moderator
but we do have a surprise guest so it is
my great pleasure to introduce bill
murray
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm surprised also
i was hoping for more time while the
moderator fumbled for words
i've been asked to read
an excerpt from huckleberry finn and the
one that i'm going to read
was
originally
published in life on the mississippi
but has been reinserted correctly i
guess
into
[Music]
huckleberry finn
mark twain
please hold your applause until we
decide as a group
whether or not he deserves applause
this is a scene between huckleberry finn
and jim
i've been in a storm here once before
with tom sawyer
and joe harper jim
it was a storm like this too last summer
we didn't know about this place
and so we got soaked
the lightning tore a big tree all the
flinders
why don't lightning cast a shadow jim
well i reckon it do but i i don't know
well it don't
i know
the sun does and a candle does
but the lightning don't
tom sawyer says it don't and it's so
chad i reckon you're mistaken about that
give me the gun i was going to see
so he stood up the gun
in the door and held it and when it
lightened
the gun didn't cast any shadow
jim says
well that's mighty curious
that's
uncommon curious
now they say that
a ghost
don't cast no shadow
why is that you reckon
of course the reason is that ghost is
made out of
lightning or else the lightning is made
out of ghosts but
i don't know which it is i i wish i know
which it is huck
well
i do too but i reckon there ain't no way
to find out
did you ever
see a ghost jim
because i'd ever see the ghost
well i reckon i asked
oh tell me about it jim tell me about it
the storms are ripping and a tearing and
carrying on soul body can hardly talk
but i reckon i'll try
long time ago when i was about
16 year old my young mars william just
dead now
was a student in dr college in the
village where we lived in
that college was a powerful
big brick building three stories high
and stood all by
herself in a big open place out to the
edge of the village well
one night in the middle of winter young
miles william he told me
to go to the college
and go upstairs to the dissecting room
on the second floor
and warm up a dead man that was there on
the table and get him soft so he can cut
him up
what for jim
i i don't know
see if he can find something in him
maybe anyways
that's what he told me
and he told me to wait that till he
comes so i take salantha
and starch art across the town
my but it was blowing and sleeting and
cold
there wasn't nobody stirring in the
streets and i could
scarcely show shove along again to win
it was most midnight and dreadful dark
i was mighty glad to get to the place
job
i unlocked the doll and went upstairs to
the discipline room
that room
was
60 feet long and 25 foot wide
and all along the wall
on both sides
was the long black gowns hanging that
the students wears when days are
chopping up the dead people
well i goes
a swinging deland
along and the shatters of them gowns
went spreading out and drawn in
along the wall and it scared me
it looked like they was
swinging their hands to get warm
well
i never looked at him no more but it
seemed like they was a doing it behind
my back just the same
there was a table about 40 foot long
down the middle of the room with four
dead people on it
laying on their backs and with their
knees up and the sheets over them
you could see the shapes
you know under the sheets well mars
william he told me to warm up the big
man with the big black whiskers
so i am kevin warren
and he didn't have no whiskers
but he had his eyes wide open
and i covered him up quick i bet you
the next one was such a ghastly sight
that
i almost let the lantern draft
well i
i
i skipped one caucus
and went for the last one
i raised up the sheet and i says
all right boss
you're the champ eyes out there
he had the
black whiskers and he was a rattling big
man
and looked wicked like a pirate
he was
naked
they all was
he was a laying on
round sticks rollers
i took the sheet off of him
and
rolled him along feet first
to the end of the table before the
fireplace
his legs was apart and his knees was you
know cocked up some so when i so when i
uprighted him
you know
he was
he
he got sat up there looking pretty
natural
you know with his feet out and his big
toes sticking out like he was warming
himself
i propped him up with the rollers you
know and then
i spread the sheet
over his back and over his head to help
warm him
and then when i was tying the corners
under his chin
by jinx
he opened his eyes
i let go and
stood off and looked at him feeling
mighty shaky
well
he didn't look at nothing
particular
and didn't do nothing so i
i know that he was good and dead yet
but i just couldn't stand them eyes you
know
it made me feel all over it just to look
at him so i pulled up the sheet clare
down over his face
and under his chin and and and tied it
hard
and then
daddy sat all naked in front with his
his head like a big snowball
and the sheet a kitten his back and
falling down on the table behind
so days out with his legs spread out but
blame if
he didn't look no better than what he
did before his head was so awful somehow
but them eyes was covered up so i
reckoned i i
let him
stand a dad and not try to improve him
up no more
well i stood
you know i stood between
his legs on the hearthstone
and and took the candle out of the
lantern
held it in my hand so to make more light
there was some embers in the fireplace
but the wood was uh you know all to the
other side and in the room
whilst i was stooping there getting
ready to go out the wood
the candle flickered
and i thought
doe man moved his legs
it kind of made me shiver
i put out my hand and felt fell to his
leg that was poked along past my left
jaw and it and it was cold as ice so i
reckon he didn't move then i then i felt
that leg was poked past my right jaw and
it was powerful cold too you see i was i
was stooping down right betwixt it
but pretty soon i i thought i see his
toes move
you know they was they was just in front
of me on both sides right
i tell you honey i was getting uneasy
you see
that was a great big old rambling
building and nobody but me in it and
that man
over me with that sheet over his face
and the wind a wailing round of place
like spirits that was in trouble and to
sleep driving again the glass and and
then
the clock struck 12 in the village and
it was so far away and the wind choked
up the sound so that was only sound like
a moan that's all
well things i
i wish
i was out in this you know
you know what what is going to become of
me
and
and this fella
moving his toes i knows it you know i
can see him move and i can i can just
feel them eyes of his and see that old
dumpling head of his all done up in the
sheet and
well so just at that minute
down he comes
right a strand on my neck
with his cold legs and kicked the candle
out
my
what did you do jim
dude well
i never done nothing
only i just got up and healed healed it
in the dark i i wasn't going to wait to
find out what he wanted
no sir i just split down the stairs and
linked it home a yelp in every jump
what did mars williams say
he said i was a fool
he went there
and found a dead man on the floor all
comfortable
and took him
and chopped him up
dodd rod i wish i'd had a hack at him
what made him uh hop on to your neck jim
well mars williams said i didn't prop
him up good with the rollers
but
i don't know
there weren't no way for a dead man to
ask no how
it might have scared some people to
death
but
jim
he weren't rightly a ghost he he was
only a dead man
didn't you ever see a real sure enough
ghost
oh you bet i have lots of them
well
tell me about them jim
all right
i will
sometime
but
the storms are slacking up now so we
better go and tend to the lines and bait
them again
[Applause]
evening
ladies and gentlemen
thank you all for coming out this
evening and
let me just introduce our panel before i
make a few opening remarks
and get the festivities underway
first i'd like to introduce shelby foote
william styron
[Music]
roy blount jr
justin kaplan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
said gentlemen
is this a beautiful store
it's a gorgeous place
it's good to see people in bookstores
[Applause]
um
thank you for coming out this evening
and
talking about a 114 year old book
i was telling mr styron we should all be
so lucky
114 years from now people
are arguing and fighting and gouging
each other's eyes out about what we've
written
[Music]
yeah that too
how you doing back there
first of all let me just begin perhaps
as twain would and tell you a brief
story
about myself to identify myself to you
my name is brent staples and i write
editorials for the new york times
[Applause]
thank you
and other things but i began my
journalistic life in chicago
and like most people perhaps
who had skipped mark twain
in junior high school
i probably would never have opened the
book
but that i was at my desk one day at the
chicago sun times which was a tabloid
where people smoked cigars and covered
murders in the mob
and one day a phone rang and there was a
gentleman with a complaint
about
huck finn
and i got the call
and the gentleman was incensed
at the fact that the word [ __ ]
appeared in huck finn
so many times a few several hundred
times i don't know the exact count
and he wanted to enlist me
in a campaign
to publish an explorated
version
of huck finn without the word [ __ ]
he suggested negro in some places slave
in the other places
and there ensued a one-hour conversation
with this gentleman
in which i tried to explain to him that
expunging the word [ __ ] from huck finn
would not expunge the history that was
associated with the word [ __ ]
that in fact
by taking that word out of the novel he
could not erase several hundred years of
slavery he could not erase
you know several hundred years
of suffering in american apartheid and
by in fact by taking it out he might in
fact obscure those years
and deny a basic reality
but
let me just say if i seem to be
demeaning the man's position i am
because it's not very smart he was
making a kind of linguistic confusion
he was making confusion between a word
and a set of historical events it
signified and he was trying to erase
them
and so after about an hour and a half
they came to you with another story and
we had to leave off that conversation
that man went on by the way
to do a national campaign
and he enlisted a bunch of school
teachers and a bunch of librarians and
he went to city councils and he said
this is a horrendous terrible
thing it's a racist term we've got to
either to get a clean version of this or
kick it out of libraries hence as uh my
colleague styron
said
in the new yorker recently
uh huck finn will never
escape the vortex of controversy that
has embraced embraced it from its very
first days
114 years ago
a boy ran away from home
he met a runaway slave and they set out
on a river
and they are effectively still there
going downstream
and we are still arguing about the
significance
of their encounter
there are
stupid criticisms of huck finn
and i'm sorry if you hold one super ones
i'm you know i'm not here
there are stupid criticisms of the puck
finn
and there are substantive criticisms of
huck fan
and
some of them are technical
my colleague ed doctorow
thinks that uh it was lazily written
a twain is this is fashion let the book
write itself let it sit around in
drawers came back to it lost continuity
and then threw together some devices
for the sawyer section at the end and
doctoral thinks this is unforgivable
um
there are other criticisms of technical
criticisms there in new york recently
but the history of this controversy
continues to continues to plague us we
had a recent editorial i mean every
editorial is really for living we had a
recent story by james the novelist jane
smiley and harpers how many of you seen
that story
i will allude to that an uh essay i'll
allude to that today
devaluing
huck finn
because in ms smiley's words
it really
it really evades
the serious business of slavery the
ugliness of slavery
it turns jim into an easy thing to
swallow
into a kind of a kind of bovine pet
on the on the raft going downstream
it evades the kind of ugliness that
harriet beecher stove
set forth in uncle tom's cabin
where slaves commit suicide are sold off
are beaten to death are starved
[Music]
i spoke with mr excuse me with
jane smiley about an hour and a half ago
she couldn't be here we tried to get her
and i asked her what had happened since
that
essay appeared and she said the hate
mail has never ceased
and the people have deceived her at
every point
um
haranguing her
about
demeaning this great work of art
and let me just read to you
a few of her comments
about huck finn
it appeals to white male readers because
it takes racism as a private matter a
private matter between huck and jim
it encourages white people not to
understand
uh the other aspects of racism if you
say you are racist they will catalog in
their minds the black people they know
and say no
the book does not serve to enlighten the
debate about the other parts of racism
it keeps leaves racism as a private
matter between huck and jim
what i what i was saying
is that there was a time when the debate
was public
and excuse me she's talking about harry
beecher stowe's novel here
the debate was public in that novel
debate goes on from the beginning to the
end
that kind of public debate
of what we would consider private issues
was a feature
of our lives before the civil war
the only point i was making that's the
only point i was making about uncle
tom's cabin
if that public debate had happened 150
years ago and gone on
and these issues had continued to be
publicly discussed perhaps we wouldn't
be there wouldn't be the kinds of
suspicion and anxiety and
institutionalized racism we see today
things have become unspeakable
i was thinking about that
the more things are debated the more
things change
talking becomes easier
about them
and so we have those two
books that side to side in that essay
uncle tom's cabin and huck finn
and there's a growth comparison that can
be made between the two
and there's some silly comparisons that
can be made between two and we can strip
them down and get to the substantive one
now the first criticism about the
appearance of the word [ __ ] of course
we can dismiss i heard i walked between
my office and eighth avenue this morning
i heard the word [ __ ] at least a
hundred times i mean
it was in the rap music it was in the
guys walking down the street driving
with one another because in new york now
it's just a harmless pronoun
hey [ __ ] what's up
in certain communities so that we
dismiss that criticism but the criticism
that twain in a cavalier way
sort of reduces
[ __ ] jim
to a kind of bovine featureless
character whose main purpose is to be a
sidekick a tonto like character
of hugs
is one i think we need to get to and i
don't think we need to we can really as
easily dismiss that
um before we i start let me just read
ralph ellison's
assessment of that
it is not all that odd that this
blackface figure of white fun is for
negroes a symbol of everything they
rejected in the white man's thinking
about race
when he appears for example in the guise
of [ __ ] jim
the negro was made uncomfortable
writing at a time when the blackface
minstrel was still popular and shortly
after a war which left even the
abolitionists weary of these problems
associated with the negro twain fitted
jim into the outlines of the minstrel
tradition
and is from behind this stereotype mass
that we that jim's dignity and human
capacity and twain's complexity emerge
so
ellison takes a different view from jane
smiling and in her absence i will have
to take her apart as we pursue and let
me just say i'm moderating here under
protest because there's no women on this
panel
as time goes on
as time goes on
as time goes on i will inject a few
points
of jane smiling
to begin i would like to turn
to mr styron
who's had some experience mr starman has
had some experience
in being charged with creating
simplistic black characters
so for those of you who are born out of
long pants then
uh i think it was 1968
uh when he
when he published his nat turner novel
and basically you know nat turner was
the
leader of a slave rebellion who caused
considerable damage and did considerable
mayhem to white people in virginia
before he was hung
and mr styron's characterization of that
came under considerable attack
primarily for nat turner's affections
and
uh attractions to a certain white woman
in the novel so mr styron knows about
this charge so
speak if you will to miss smiley's
charge please
well
uh i would add just as a post script to
uh
what brent
staples said about um
i'm gonna
not use the euphemism
n-word is that all right just say oh
[ __ ] just as it should be said because
that's
what we all understand it to be
a lot of people pussyfoot around it
and
um
i i'm rather defensive
and
collegial about huck finn because
uh
i was attacked too as brent staples just
pointed out
curiously enough
i can be
exact about the num the word [ __ ] and
its frequency in huckleberry finn
because
john wallace the black educator that
brent just mentioned
who did indeed
publish a totally bolderized version of
huckleberry finn from which all
uses of the word [ __ ]
were removed
uh made a count and
and the the actual count is 231 times
in the confessions of nat turner my
novel
i made a count or i had my uh an
employee make a account and it was 188
times now curiously enough
i think this is an interesting
sociological fact
uh that when the book came out it was
my book came out it was attacked on all
levels you can possibly imagine
it was attacked for
racism sexism
it was attacked for bigotry
i was accused of being morally senile
of being corrupt
of being a
a a nasty
race-baiter you name it i was called it
but i was never once
criticized for using the word [ __ ] 188
times
which i think is an interesting effect
in itself
my own view about
jane smiley who is a writer of extreme
intelligence
and talent
is that this is one of the stupidest
essays ever written
i read it with
growing
dread and fascination
as i realized that there was some sort
of
ghastly
uh subtext
there which i couldn't quite grasp
but that virtually every other sentence
was either a canard
an exaggeration or to my mind an outro
outright lie
now
to me the most single i i jotted this
down the car coming down because i had
the article from harpers in my uh brief
briefcase
and i think
the place where she misses the point
most directly
and most
stupidly
is and i'm gonna i'm gonna uh quote it
this is from jane smiley i'm one
defender too great okay
fair enough to give credit to huck
suggests that
um
the only racial insight
americans of the 19th and 20th century
are capable
of
is a recognition of the obvious
that blacks slave and free
are human
now on the surface that's perfectly
perfectly unexceptional it seems to me
until you examine it
in the light of huck finn himself
because to my mind
the the vivid moral
courage
of huck finn himself the the boy the 12
year old boy
is
that he's the only person virtually only
white person in the book
who does see
that huck finn that jim
is human
this was at times the slave period of
unspeakable horror and cruelty
in which black people
were bought and sold
routinely like animals
and i think when you examine the the
character of huck finn
you see just that that he's the only one
who recognizes
jim's
humanity
and therefore
from my mind i'm out here i'm out here
right directly in front of you right
down the aisle
okay
uh let me just say let me just counter
to that okay briefly
miss smiley in taking the the counter
example
and be and any of you gentlemen please
jump in after i ask this question please
don't sit there demurely especially you
mr foote
in in her counter example
of uncle tom's cabin she talks about the
variety of characters in the slave
experience she talks about the slave
woman who in fact you know kills a child
instead of letting the child be sold out
right she talks about the characters who
acquiesce to slavery the characters who
fight it the characters who are cunning
and quiet in their attack to evade
punishment she talks about a whole
range of character experiences one of
her beefs
and this is smiley's beef not mine one
of her beefs with this character of jim
is that he's just a little bit too loyal
that he's just a little bit too
featureless that he's just a little bit
too much
the sort of menstrual
goodie
who can be you know amusing for rooms
full of white folks
well i mean that's
you know i think that's true uh but
still i mean
the uh jim's uh the garrison keeler did
a show a while back that james earl
jones played jim and uh garrison played
huh 20 years later they ran back into
each other
jim had become a famous actor in europe
as a matter of fact
and jim was saying that he didn't
remember the book that way you know i
mean he said he i read your book huck
but that's not the way i remember
and wound up with huck trying to borrow
twenty dollars
um and so i mean it's a book written by
a white man and if it but interesting
there's uh
uh you know the joel chandler harris
wrote it was uncle remus stories
and uh which are wonderful stories and
all now the intro the little
introductory sections where the little
white kid talks to uncle remus in a
condescending way that are just awful
but once you get the stories of real
good stories but i don't there's not
none of that kind of condescension in
huck finn if you go back and read the
snotty little white kid talking to uncle
remus and that's really unpleasant to
read i don't find anything in
huckleberry finn at all unpleasant that
way it seemed to me huck and
and and jim are you know on the same
level whereas huck is a kid so that's me
but
um but then there's a charles chestnut
it was a black writer wrote some had a
storyteller named uncle julius and it's
instructive to compare
uh a black writer's uncle julius with
the white writer's uncle remus and uh
the ogre genius is a lot cleverer and
more wily and less sweet less nice than
and it seems to me that a if a black
person had written huck finn
uh i mean it's such an
academic uh thing but uh if if
it had not been a white person writing
uh uh
hug finn that jim might have been a
fuller and more interesting character
but that's what i'm reminded of uh
don powell said once that criticisms of
her latest novel boiled down to the
critics saying
if they had my automobile they wouldn't
go visit my folks they'd visit there
and uh and i think
it's outfits is such a wonderful book i
mean you can it's a great thing about it
is it keeps coming up and it keeps
giving us chances to talk about the uh
about things like this i mean it's a
great text for uh pretext for
uh discussions about delicate racial
issues because it's fun to read if
nothing else and it also has its
limitations and like everything else it
goes completely crazy in the last few
years mr foot
what about
miss smiley's
notion that she's trying to get at she
admits today that she didn't do this as
successfully as she might have
in her harper's essay which i i know you
hold in low esteem but
she
said
one of those distinctions she's trying
to make she's trying to make a
distinction between
a work of literature
that ex makes express on the surface a
discussion
about slavery and social conditions
among the characters among the white
characters among the black characters
between white characters and black
characters and a book that does not
what do you make of her observation
i make it uh practically value this
i judge a novel in large part by its
writing and i think as a novelist i know
a great novel from a bad novel huck
finn's a great novel uncle tom's cabin
is a bad novel and
i can't back that up i just believe it
that's what i sensed out of reading the
two books i never managed to finish
uncle tom's cabin
twain is a
is somebody that has to be gotten that
from a sort of angle he's a very strange
man
he's known for his humor and even for
his wit he had very little of either
what he had was an enormous sense of the
ridiculous he posits two things that
just won't fit together
and uh he brings that off in a marvelous
way and that's what he has twain himself
was a colorful character and
twain being so colorful makes his
writing colorful there's a little story
about twain what he was like he was a
member of the players club here and he
hung out there good deal
and members took turns as uh with jobs
that they had to do like he was chairman
of the visitors committee one time
he was in the bar having a drink
and a stranger came up a visitor
obviously and said could you tell me
where the men's room is mark twain said
here piss on me i'm chairman of the
visit
x-rated cut that out of the tape
[Laughter]
he uh that's twain
and that's in huckleberry finn too
that kind of thing and uh it's not in
uncle tom's cabin i'll tell you
[Applause]
um yes mr kaplan
one i i wrote a rejoinder to uh jane
smiley whom by the way i i respect and
admire as a fiction writer enormously
he's getting ready to murder her when he
says that
i wrote a rejoinder to her in in the as
an essay in the new york times book
review and
i have any number of bones to pick with
her but but the point that was just
brought up
that she claims that uh
tom's that
uncle tom's cabin allows a number of
voices to participate i think she's got
a novel confused with uh drive time
call-in radio
that's not the function of
of a novel the function of a novelist is
to present a point of view and and a set
of characters looked at very closely
uh and another point that i'd like to
make is that uh well since roy brought
up
the subject of uncle remus wonderful
stories i've always thought of of
huckleberry finn as the equivalent of
the the tar baby in
in uncle remus story that it's the
entire baby that we can't get rid of it
can't get rid of it it's stuck to us
it's mark twain is our prayer rabbit
we will have to live with it it's
painful
but it's wonderful too well tell me what
do you find painful about the book
that it it will cause a lot of pain to
to people for example i can imagine a
young black person in a high school
teaching situation
being horribly mortified and and hurt by
the
200 whatever it is repetitions of the 31
231 and by the way you'll find
not quite so many but a significant
number of uses of the word [ __ ] and
uncle tom's cabinet and no one squawks
about that
but it does cause pain
and
i think the way to answer that is to
suggest that
uh huckleberry finn is not little little
house on the prairie and that one of the
functions of of great fiction is to
disorient and dismay and to to upset you
to make you think and feel differently
and this book certainly does it
[Applause]
one more time down this path mr styron
in the new yorker
you mentioned that you thought
in passing that
twain had an ambivalent feelings about
race
and could you flesh out
what what brings you to think that and
what judgment you make about that
well i could i would probably have to
flesh it out by saying that i said it
because
i think all americans throughout
history white and black
have had ambivalent feelings about race
specifically speaking about white people
uh
i always like to
recall early conversation with my
late and beloved friend robert pen
warren
who had an extraordinary understanding
about race situation in america as well
as anyone i know
in his time
and he simply said
i think he was probably
being
slightly flamboyant i remember being on
a walk with him he says don't you
realize all americans are racist he said
thomas jefferson was racist
abraham lincoln was racist
he says we're all racist
but he was trying to i think say that
if you remove the word race racist and
pare that down somehow
he was trying to say what i
recapitulated in the statement you
attribute to me in the new yorker which
is
uh
i said huckleberry finn reveals the mind
of a writer with equivocal feelings
about race
and i would like to assert
as
unequivocally as i possibly can at this
moment that almost every american
has equivocal feelings about race
and it would have been entirely
unnatural seems to me
as splendid a man as as as uh mark twain
was
as compassionate and warm as we and and
and a decent person as he was
it's amazing to me that he had so little
racism
given the fact that he was a child of
his time
that he grew up in a town which knew
slavery and that he had actually joined
briefly the confederate army
i'm astounded that that this book
with this heavy weight of
race consciousness on it and the heavy
burden of hatred that was hovering over
missouri in that
time that the book is so free of all of
these horrible things
that have haunted us for all these many
years that's my view of the thing
[Applause]
i think that uh i honestly believe that
huck bear finn is the great anti-slavery
tract of them all
uh huck
about as racist as you can get
and what he does is he recognizes that
jim is a man a man a wise and good man
and he says um
he was going to help him escape he said
i'll all right i'll go to hell
but
he believes as a racist that his
sympathies for jim was going to send him
to hell
and and that's the turning point of the
novel it's the point novel builds up to
and then floats away from
uh his recognition that jim is a man
like any other man and it's very clear
to huck that that's his feeling and he's
willing to go to hell believe in it
we're all racist uh
robert pen warren's right
we all have that i was brought up on it
i was not allowed to use the word [ __ ]
in my home
my folks would not let me use that word
they wanted me to say colored people
which is to my mind about his band
but
it was a word that was in common use for
everyday things people who didn't say
the word when it applied to a person
applied it to things brazil nuts were
called negatoes
a slingshot was called a [ __ ] shooter
now this was utterly unconscious it's
about as racist as you can get but it
was no thought i remember coming home
from school one day and nellie was there
she worked for us for 28 years black
woman incidentally made three dollars a
week when she started 28 years later was
making 12 dollars a week i've
sometimes rather realized it every
mostly food i ever put in my mouth every
thread of clothes i ever had on my back
every hour of education i ever had
anything else came out of exploiting
black people i knew that knew that
perfectly well it doesn't reduce my
racism but it helps me to reduce it
i came home from school
and nellie was there and i was looking
around for my slingshot and i said nelly
where's my [ __ ] shooting she said
i think it's back on your bureau back
then it was to her as unconsciously said
as to me saying it it was just a word
that was in the language that applied to
things it didn't somehow it didn't apply
to people
uh it
and
you
for twain not to use it would have been
the crazy thing
and somehow another people can't get
past that word and it's painful it's
like the confederate battle flag it
really hurts people they see it as a
representation of all that's oppressing
them for so many
so many years
as as my st in my stature as honorary
women i need to ask one more question
and then i'll open up the
the audience you can
join in this year that we've heard from
everyone um
we also asked mary gordon
to come and join this panel but she was
she wasn't able to
and he did say at the time that um
that huck finn is a huck finn is a
little boy's book it's a boy's men's
book
and it's mainly about uh flight from
female power and authority
and in some sense i guess to put a few
words in mary's mouth that leaves it
sort of half a book mr foote
it is a boy's book i read it as a boy
with great pleasure liked it better than
tom sawyer
uh what is interesting about twain is he
doesn't like tom sawyer either and
huckleberry finn
tom sawyer represents literary things
and uh
copying out of books and things and hook
is a natural force and so he's jim
and the juxtapose hook against tom
and jim against the people around him is
uh it's great to train his credit how
well they come off by that comparison
yeah i think women i'm sorry yeah women
do just seem generally to play the role
an ugly finn of getting in the way of
the of the men wanting to do what they
want to do or nagging them in one thing
or another
but in lots of women's novels i can
think of the men just
seem to play they're all getting away
with women
also you have to remember that huck is
really on the run from his father yes
there's only one brief mention of
even reminding you that once had a
mother's it's
not very important i think
what having to do with race i mean
further
mark twain talked about himself as being
a great mongrel and all sorts of things
and there's a book by shelly fisher
fishkin called
waz huck black which i thought sounded
silly until i read it and in fact
she made the point that uh
southern white
characters and comic novels before huck
had had completely different speech
rhythms and that huck was the first
white character in the comic novel to to
sound to have a little bit of the rhythm
of
of african-americans and by the way a
lot of english visitors to to to the
states in the 1840s came back and were
appalled but by the fact by recognizing
that
that uh a lot of white kids most white
kids growing up on the plantation that
is the sons of the slave owners sounded
more like slaves than like white people
up north
it was part of the culture
yeah i mean that's a great the south is
a i
i have argued that southern culture is
africa celtic or celtic african as
opposed to
exposed to anglo-saxon and it makes it's
a big difference from the northeast for
that reason you know
you can i was just thinking that uh
a lot i mean almost all it seems to me
great things in american culture are
mixtures of black and white and this are
obviously so i mean
all of american popular music that's any
good is that and seems to me that
awkward in some ways is uh
sort of like rock and roll and then it's
a mixture of black rhythm and black
blues with
uh white adolescence and white marketing
right right
but
i think and
and i'm and i'm not just asking this but
what accounts
for
the staying power of this book surely
not just his goodness i mean a lot of
good books
that are wonderfully written
but 114 years out
you know where if you some of these
questions that i've asked some
and some of the observations that were
made were made the first
time it was certainly not those about
race but others about his general
crudeness and so forth were made the
first time it uh it appeared what
accounts for this book staying power i
don't think there's any doubt about what
counts for it to stay in power it's a
great book
uh hemingway said america literature
came out of huckleberry finn and i think
he's close to the truth on that uh it
taught us the use of our own language uh
this american language has been used in
vulnerable skits
and been used by one man before twain
with enormous effect that's abraham
lincoln who really knew how to use
american english but uh it's mark crane
who was the literary person who spoke
the american language
uh in the way he does in huck finn and
his other books incidentally if you want
to talk about racism and those problems
read putting ed wilson that'll that'll
get you straight on twain
yes also
living under the shadow of all these
other
rather serious issues it's easy to
forget that this is a very funny book
and it's a great adventure story and
then let's not devalue those things can
i just read one quick short thing please
the the kind of appeal that mark twain
has it everybody that hardly anybody
else does that stays there
this is in a funeral when the place was
packed full the undertaker he slid
around in his black gloves with his
softy soothing ways putting on the last
touches and getting people and things
all ship shape and comfortable and
making no more
sound than a cat he never spoke he moves
people around he squeezed in late people
he opened up passageways done it all
with nods and signs with his hands then
he took his place over against the wall
he was the softest glidingest
stealthiest man i ever see
there weren't no more smile to him than
there is to a ham
then the reverend hobson opened up slow
and solemn and begun to talk and
straight off the most outrageous route
busted out in the cellar a body ever
heard it was only one dog but he made a
most powerful racket and he kept it up
right along parson he had to stand there
over the coffin and wait you couldn't
hear yourself think
it was right awkward and nobody didn't
seem to know what to do but pretty soon
they see that long-legged undertaker
make a sign to the preacher much as to
say don't you worry just depend on me he
stooped down and began to glide along
the wall just his shoulders showing over
the people's heads so he glided along
and the pow-wow racket getting more and
more outrageous all the time
at last when he'd gone around two sides
of the room he disappeared down cellar
then in about two seconds we heard a
whack and
the dog he finished up with the most
amazing howl or two and then everything
was dead still
and the parsons begun his solemn talk
where he left off in a minute or two
there comes the undertaker's back and
shoulders gliding along the wall again
so he glided and glided around three
sides of the room
then rose up and shaded his mouth with
his hands and stretched his neck out
towards the preacher
over the people's heads and says in a
kind of coarse whisper he had a wrap
he drooped down and glided along the
wall into this place you can see it's a
great satisfaction to the people because
naturally they wanted to know a little
thing like that don't cost nothing and
it's just the little things that makes
them man
[Applause]
that answer is especially there weren't
no more popular men in town than that
undertaker that answers the question
doesn't it i think it does if anybody
wants to ask the question as we go i'll
you can stand at the mic right there
and fire away
this isn't a question um could one of
the members of the panel read mark
twain's notice
at the beginning of the book
yeah
uh notice persons attempting to find a
motive in this narrative will be
prosecuted
persons attempting to find a moral in it
will be banished
persons attempting to find a plot in it
will be shot
[Applause]
any questions
mr captain we were earlier discussing um
before we came on
the the virtues of uh
tampering with a great work of art or by
re restoring
parts that were were lost and
or you know putting in things from other
drafts how do you think the novel has
fared under under the restorations in
this edition
well i i have to say that that this new
edition which is very handsome and very
ample and full of information it is not
meant to
to establish a new text or to replace
the the uh the huckleberry finn that we
all know love and presumably have read
as well
what it does is to
is to
supplement the text and
also feed our natural curiosity about
about how authors go about making books
that that we really value for example i
find it fascinating
if you to look at the
at the title page of charles dickens's
uh a christmas carol and to see that the
character that we now know is tiny tim
was once known as puny pete and a few
other
alliterative names like that it's not a
matter of great moment but if you care
about an author's work
sometimes you care about how he goes
about making it and what what decisions
that that he makes and uh
the the current edition involves a
number of decisions
to excise material for example the
wonderful
ghost story that that bill murray read
before so beautifully
is a
story and on the same level of quality
as mark twain's uh terrific golden arm
but you but you can imagine that
an author might feel that a monologue
story like this might interrupt the flow
and momentum of his narrative and he
might say very sagely well i like this
but you know as good writers do who are
self-editors they say the more i love it
the more i think i'll have to kill it
you have to get rid of it
and there are a number of other
decisions uh
that you'll see at work in this edition
see i don't think it's tampering with
the text i think it feeds as i said our
natural curiosity i'd be interested to
see the first draft of hamlet
you might discover that that shakespeare
decided to kill
claudius off in act one and then
realized to his horror that there was no
play
we have a question yes first a very
quick observation it's been my
perception that
uh one index of narrow-mindedness seems
to be the ability to focus only on a
single word
i don't know if you gentlemen will agree
with that
but it does bring out the the the larger
issue which very simply is
how do you reconcile
the tension between
the needs of those who might have
certain sensitivities
and the legitimate
need for having certain literature as a
part of our history
where we can look back on it
recognizing that it was not a perfect
world in those days and that our history
exists warts and all
yeah
now i don't see any need to reconcile
things no but but certainly reality and
this is history that's the way things
were this is in quite a historical novel
but the thing is it's not recognized as
such as was pointed out a young black
teenager in school
uh might very well be offended uh seeing
things
on the page which he would have no
difficulty uttering to his friends
walking down that same school hallway
and that's what i can't quite get
straight
well that's what makes the book
so fascinating i think has been one
little
tiny fragment of
huck finn has not been brought up
tonight for some reason it usually is
it's a scene toward the end
where tom sawyer comes in he's been on a
steamboat
and he's reporting to his aunt what what
has happened on the
on the on the trip down to arkansas
and uh he says there was an explosion
on the boat
and his aunt says
well tom land's sake anyone hurt
he says often
gnome killed a [ __ ]
now this is an extraordinary
statement by modern standards
but in the context of 19th century
it has to be regarded as a kind of line
that would have been said
without any sense of prejudice
the the word uh uh
is not the same as uh
words like uh
wap or [ __ ] or hunky uh which are all
scornful the word [ __ ] by no means
necessarily scornful although uh it's an
indication of racism of course but it's
it's not meant invariably as an insult
maybe i should uh
jump in just a little bit at this point
as a as a kind of street archaeologist
of new york
um or
what happens
or anthropologists in new york excuse me
what happens
in any derisive term
there's a certain kind of license that's
allowed for in-group people that's not
allowed for our group people right i
mean that exists among jews in new york
it exists among italians in new york my
italian friends call you the guinea all
the time right but if i would walk into
a room and say guinea to an unknown
italian i'm about to have my face
rearranged right so there's in-group
licenses out group license and that that
there's a kind of flux that exists in
language especially in big cities like
this it goes back and forth and those
boundaries were about to rub up against
each other all the time
so you hence you could find someone who
would be who would find [ __ ] and
twain's mouth objectionable
and who would find [ __ ] in uh you know
public enemy the rap group or cypress
hill you know perfectly euphonius
question
yeah one of the most striking things
that i remember about that harper's
magazine article was the point that the
author made that
uh huck finn was not a great novel suey
generous but it had been so canonized by
what you might call a cable of white men
and she did point out that there were a
number of structural flaws with the
novel
i think it's a very
devastatingly sadistic
piece of work as a novel
but what bothers me about it is that i
think it goes over the heads of most of
the people that read it i think you have
to be very sophisticated and worldly to
really get what twain was getting at and
when you put it in the hands of
elementary or junior high school even
high school kids especially a lot of
white kids are in a mixed group
you're getting people that
don't see you know the brilliance of the
novel and what you get is pandering to
the worst common denominator and it's
the same problem i have with august
wilson's plays i mean i don't care how
many pulitzer prizes he wins if you're
in a mixed group and he's got [ __ ]
every other line you know you wonder why
white people like him so much you wonder
if it's because he's really brilliant or
because it's really feeding their worst
instinct and their basest feelings on
some level and that's the problem i
really have with huck finn
well i think it's i'm sorry i mean
i think that uh i've been looking at
[ __ ] particularly all through here and
while i reread the book and it seems to
me that mark twain is always
he's never cat using it casually you
seem to me i mean people are using it
occasionally but every time it's used it
comes in a moment when uh i was i don't
know
where
so you know so the in the next sentence
it's like the steamboat thing nobody was
killed you know nobody was hurt you know
i mean it's kind of he's obviously
uh and i could i i mean i agree that it
could cause trouble in classroom i
wonder whether anybody ought to be made
to read
it might spoil it to make it compulsory
yeah but
and i can't
a lot of things would bother me i think
if i were a black reader but uh but i do
think that that
mark twain was courageously going at the
sore point there and he knew that the he
was not just tossing the word off he's
using it in a really
embarrassing way a lot of times
the novelist david bradley the novelist
david bradley said
uh that that he says that that
calculation mr blount just spoke of
david bradley said that calculation is
so precise
that you can iterate the difference
between
tom and huck
yeah the way they use it and he said
when huck uses it
he's generally talking about a person
you know and when tom uses it he's
generally talking about an animal
so
but that may in fact be a little bit
much for eighth graders and that's one
of the debates that's happening now and
um without taking too much time i think
that the novel ought to be taught but it
ought to be taught
you know what i'm saying
somebody's got somebody's got to go
there and say
make the kind of observations that
writers are making every day about the
differences in uses depending on who's
speaking and in group and out group and
so on next question
yeah i'm
a slight uh change of
of subject
twain
expressed his um
distaste for people like walter scott
and made fun of
of americans adulation of european
culture
and i'd like to hear uh any of the panel
speak to that um
side of twain with relationship to uh
to huck finn
twain uh
twain could
couldn't abide what he thought of his
stuffiness out of anybody under any
circumstances uh those of you who've
read his uh
his
his essay on um
[Music]
thank god i've forgotten his name
james fennimore cooper
oh yeah
it's a very funny thing he takes him to
test something awful and it's very very
funny
but later on in life somebody asked him
about jane austen he said well
i can read fennimore couple for money if
i'm paid to do it but i couldn't read i
couldn't read jane austen for money
uh i just would like to make uh one
comment and then a question for the
panel but on twain being compulsory i
once heard a quote attributed to twain
where he said that he didn't think
anyone should be forced to read his book
especially young people because he had
been forced to read the king james bible
as a young man and he didn't think he
had ever recovered
that was twain on compulsory
the other question i have for the panel
is someone alluded to the last part of
the book
uh and i think there's pretty much
universal agreement that when tom sawyer
re-enters the novel
there's a deflation
um one thing that occurred to me and i
just i don't know if anyone else has
written about this
is that perhaps twain is
having a social commentary that this
book's written
20 years after the emancipation
proclamation and life in america still
isn't very good for those of african
descent
and in the same way the gym is in that
cabin
legally a free man
and yet still
treated as a piece of property by tom
sawyer and i was just curious if there
has been any
comment on that if twain had that in
mind with the last i'm always looking
for a way to defend the last fifth of
the book
yeah all through the book there are
people treating other people and even
dogs and things like objects and i mean
and uh
and it just amounts to this sort of
crescendo of absurd uh
uh objectification in enrollment and i i
was just i just read the last part uh
this afternoon the first time in a long
time and it's just really crazy you know
it's but maybe it's appropriately crazy
i mean maybe what else are you gonna do
i don't know it's just it's sort of
tom sawyer kind of messes things up
whereas see me that hawk and jim are
often in pretty i mean not the same
shape
but huck understates everything and not
just about slavery but about huck is a
gravely abused child and his father
nearly beats him to death and the way he
describes being nearly beaten to death
is uh
is understated in the same way that he
talks about
slavery whereas tom just blows
everything i mean
builds inflates everything builds
everything up so it's a sudden shift in
in style that is hard to adjust to yeah
i i agree with whether that it's uh
appropriately crazy i mean i'm willing
to live with it it doesn't bother me
that much but but i i think you take a
more charitable view of the ending if
you realize that the whole premise of
the book is a little loony to begin with
it's an impossible premise and that is
why would
why would jim be running farther down
south every minute
he's going in the wrong direction
and huck says why would a runaway slave
run south
well that's what mrs miss smiley
got very angry about
why
go down the river
go down the river which when they could
have crossed over into illinois which is
about two miles away
well that's exactly like saying why
doesn't hamlet kill claudius in act one
you can't do it
please don't be shy step right up
um my favorite uh line in the novel is
when jim says that french people have a
different word for everything um so
maybe we have francophiles after us
novel but uh
i think that the uh
that
when i read the james smiley piece i
came away i kept wanting to say to the
article it's the best
boy you could hope to find in
mississippi
in the late
1800s i just that's the point yeah
yeah and uh
i write the subways all the time and
what's
happening now which is making me very
uncomfortable is
uh
teenagers using the word [ __ ] um it's
started with darker skinned hispanics
and now lighter-skinned hispanics
and asians in middle eastern teenagers
in groups mixed racial groups and you
see people on the subway it's the older
folks that are like because here's you
know a korean or a chinese kid going
damn [ __ ] to his friend and it's all
the adults with their shoulders up
but the kids are just
talking and i'm waiting for something to
happen
you know it's something
what's going to happen is the usages are
going to wax and wane what you're
looking at you're looking at the
language stew of the city and it's
uncomfortable but it's like tectonic
plates of meaning that scrape against
one another and there's kind of it is
unseemly and uncomfortable sometimes
when that happens but
count yourself lucky to be in new york
right
right now we got all these mics out here
so you know don't be shy step up and you
can be on tv
at that point too but you can step in
the back and we'll do your makeup
at that point
do you think
gentlemen
that
southern writers in particular
are just too enamored of the menstrual
type
um ellison brings ellison tries to
defend
or try to tries to
plumb
modern
black revulsion at the gym character
um
but
do you think that that and three of you
are southerners so i put that to you do
you think southern writers are
historically
just too enamored of that type
i think there's some truth in the charge
which is
an effective type it's been used over
and over again i wrote a novel in which
uh
i had to write about some bourgeois
blacks and i've never known him because
while blacks all i've known his servants
and doctors and judges and things so i
had a terrible time
familiarizing myself with it enough to
try to handle it
i think that that side of black life has
been neglected
i look forward to a time when black
writers
can write
with about white people
the way white people feel free to write
about black people
i
i feel that nearly all black riders are
carrying a heavy burden a very heavy
burden which i wish they could unload
amen mr
mr foot
[Music]
hard to stand up under but i think the
twain that we've been talking about
to charge him with being backward on
this subject race
uh is to ignore every everything else
about his personality uh he was not on
the back of anything uh
when you read his his complaints about
the spanish-american war it makes
vietnam protests look mild indeed
twain is fierce on the subject of war
uh he's fierce on the subject of
lynching uh and he's out front of
everything else and why you think he's
not out front on this racial thing i'm
not too sure
because he is well i'm just mis i'm just
miss smiling so don't right i'm with you
right yes sir i'm no twain scholars so
maybe you guys can do a little homework
for me i read this book by julie smith
that i really enjoyed that mentions mr
kaplan uh called huckleberry fiend and
one of the sub themes of it is uh
that
twain's best work was heavily edited if
not almost co-authored by his wife
olivia langdon and uh
that a bunch of the stuff that didn't
get into print was the stuff that olivia
langdon didn't work on or didn't edit is
is this uh just fiction or is there
anything to that
and i i think that's highly exaggerated
and also if you would realize that the
let's say the the dynamic of someone
like mark twain it's very easy for him
to
to blame self-censorship on his wife
it's a very easy way out
he could write i mean he didn't need an
editor i mean one thing the man could do
is right he could right the thing that
has to be held on in my mind about twain
is
never mind an author's personality but
twain's personality is so much a part of
his writing as well keep it in mind he
uh
he saw himself
as a ridiculous person on many occasions
and frequently said so
i heard about him one time he was uh
he liked to be alone and nobody bothered
him while he was writing but he didn't
want to shut the door because he didn't
want to close the world off it's a
strange thing i have that same thing i
don't know where it comes from but
anyway he's sitting there riding at his
desk and the door's open there's a hall
outside
and one of his little girls rode past on
the tricycle
and he frowned
and in a minute she came back the other
way and he frowned worse
and the third time she passed he got up
threw the pen down and said damn it no
writer should ever be married
but but
the reason i keep stressing uh
twain's personality is i think it's so
much a part of her hook
everything about him
and uh
no matter how
rough and tumble he is
this is a frontier society he's writing
about and huck's gonna light out the
territory
uh
no matter what he does this this
essential
level and this is the wrong word but
this is the essential uh humor to the
man is uh is it permeates everything he
writes i keep thinking i have to respond
to the menstrual thing but i don't know
exactly what to say i mean seeing the
one thing about jim also not being a
strong i mean a more assertive character
or something is that you can just see it
working in the book how little option
jim has to speak up i mean uh he's got
to
i mean jeez he's i mean he's going to be
he can't say he can't he's going to be
sold down the river he's in terrible and
huck is in the same trouble with him
most of them but i mean he's not going
to tell down the river but he's also
he's trapped with the king and the duke
because they're going to turn jim in as
a runaway slave um and
there are a lot
uh black people in the south were
certainly repressed and it came out now
i never really had much sense of the
minstrel character but there's the blues
character for instance which i do admire
i saw menstrual shows when they were in
their glory back in the late 20s algae
fields and lassies white and all of them
it'd be extremely embarrassing to see
one of them today and these people in
blackface and everything
really appreciate you but
this this mark twain thing
this this racism at twain i don't think
anybody today can realize how it
permeated all of society it was
absolutely part of our lives and it was
made part of our lives probably on
purposes just some genius invented it so
as you have cheap labor all your life
uh it's it's not easy to understand also
anyone who
like shelby and i i think roy uh were
you born during segregation yeah i never
went to school with a black person until
graduate school that's right
well anyone who
has been through segregation like like
all of us
in the south
uh remember
truly to my my lacerating experience
and i say that because i think
it's overlooked
that as horrible
as
segregation
was and jim crow
it worked
a terrible
it created a terrible wound
from the souls of a lot of white people
too
right i'm not trying to get white people
off the hook
but
but this system which was part of
history sort of inexorably rolled up
as a result of of agricultural
capitalism
created a terrible
burden
for an entire society it has to be
remembered
and if some white people have any sense
at all they remember that and that i
mean what i hate is when people uh like
ronald reagan say i don't have a racist
bone in my body i didn't know i mean
anybody that that's pre-racist doesn't
mean you haven't gotten as far as the
rest of it
it's like saying he doesn't have a bone
in his body
we got a question here
one of the things i haven't uh seen or
heard much about tonight is the
except for the last person who mentioned
self or censorship by his wife
twain had an extreme
need for my reading of him
to be respectable to be civilized and i
think the extreme
case of that was the book personal
recollections of joan of arc
the site of him did not sell very well
that's why we're not here tonight
talking about jonah bark
that
i think probably that
conflict between
as mr foot said the man he really was
and uh
the man that uh
you know he wanted to be the respectable
uh kind of person probably helped
power his books
well if he were all together
consistently be a much less interesting
person right i i have the uh the grim
duty of writing a an introduction to
joan of arc which is a book that really
fills me full of dismay but but it
becomes an interesting chapter in in
this writer's life because he he
uh he very often alternates between
let's say autonomous urges and then the
need as you say to be respectable and to
sell well and
he does sell out and he hates himself
for it and there's
there's no straight line in this man's
life
thank you um
i guess we'll
wind up
and uh
let the gentleman sign books if they
wish but at this point i guess i can
drop the guys in my disguise of jane
smiley and tell you what i think
basically i look upon twain
as one of the ver one of very few real
genuine seers in our culture or in the
world
i think of
to spread them far apart i think of
shakespeare as one seer i think of a
fellow especially on the issue of race i
think of othello as a play that saw all
of the psychology of race hundreds of
years before it ever manifested itself
on a grand scale saw it all
and i think of my fellow virginian
thomas jefferson
at that level
um in the founding of the republic and i
think of twain a little a little time
later as a real seer of the complexities
of race and this real dance that will go
on in perpetuity between blacks and
whites
and we're still dancing it because we're
still still here tonight and thank you
all for coming good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
you're watching about books which airs
saturday and sunday nights on c-span